Hello, my name is Catherine Parker and I'm going to have a conversation with Shanequa Gowans
for Visible Lives an Oral History Project
at the New York Public Library. It is January 21st
2015 and this is being recorded at City College
of New York.
Isn't that what it's called? of New York City's Oh
you don't you don't go to City College, OK.
So, when how old are you. 25
one.
And what is your disability.
Growing up is hard of hearing and I read
lips I found though that I had a little
bone problem with ?
Growing up it was, you I know I didn't realize it. My biggest dis-my biggest issue
was hard of hearing because I wasn't able to like
understand, basically, like hearing people so I
knew as uh, growing up I was able to like um
to listen to people by reading lips and
I guess by watching a lot.
So nobody never understood that but my family so they knew I had hearing problems
but I didn't understand that ,the type of hearing problems I had. So as a young ?ages since, I didn't
like really kinda like, you know, kind hear because
I wasn't you know understanding what was really going on because people used
to go she's crazy, you she can't hear, she's deaf
she don't know what she talking about.
So no I don't like things up when we make a mistake of actually seen
and I used to play channel you know anybody lake or my
name would be three to one it's two times and.
Whisper room was kind of like heart so in a go when I felt like people are still getting up just
kind of like in I didn't feel comfortable like
participating in a lot of groups because I feel like
I was actually left out which I was or I was in the group but I
was like sitting there in the kind of quiet because I was able to listen
to these and watch what's going on around me
so that was kind of me being a Christian is a hard a year so I was
able to become a stronger better person is
by reading lips and watching people.
So when I mean when when I went to school ahead of
time tough times like an air flight member really like
in their routine and sometimes that was Irene but certain words I think once I
found out that I had a speech discrimination with them to
hear and so I didn't stay in a minute or so. So I don't know
what I mean when I was young growing up now though. It's like an old party here
again here interesting. You're here in the X. in China only
focus.
Only things that I like to do and when I was growing
up it was Conolly it was easy because I was
quite doing what I came to the things that I can see to do
. But being in a new group I always
wanted to get in
and do what was rolling me we wanted to with the New World was able to
catch up with everybody and you see it so
it was late.
Affiliate I was just like you know being in the universe and a lot of the group a group
of people who've been trying to be friends with him would be like five or
ten people because I always had to look around and watch everybody's talking
and it's kind of hard it was foolishly so it is why
you know what kind
. So you're How hard of hearing are you CAN
YOU ARE SO do you wear a
hearing aid that you are hearing aid and when you don't have your hearing aid on are you
completely deaf.
Those are hard to hear like right now. I've been hearing strong all firm right. I mean my left
side because we want to hear an exceptionally degree appear in it. OK
so I guess it
actually has lips it actually can spring right engine is actually
right now of the hearing aids and they actually do it is hard to balance it
sometimes used to hear my hearing because I didn't get here in
the world of around two thousand each at best the first
time I get a free spirit leaks that it had in the
units in the understand how did you figure out what didn't work
so I knew this but down here really slick though.
What happened right here in the US Some of the tone comes up so I noticed
lately now like sometimes it's like what am I hearing in this year is like a here I
came here to things but if I hear everybody look decide my attention turns on this I knew
somebody is calling me so I have to teach the person so it's late
even if I were going in like a job.
The old it's kind of hard because I know there's a gene to late taking the notice stayed
a list a lot of time in school because I'm
trying to get like a new Tikker which I fill it was kind of hard to do with it
because I was used to work but in no way did it was hard to
hear the professor told in the media right at the same time.
So let me try to really do try to communicate it was so
easily that I have a little bit
different mission so that was kind of getting inside school college for
me and and in C. They need to ignore outing in my services
because. Now I know they did it was hard at the college and
the people need to understand. So it's kind of hard they had to fight at the same time I mean you
know what I did in what type of services didn't you that's
what we did I feel comfortable with. So they started using certain
services and they had to like try they definitely sometimes it is hard even though
they gave me a duty but sometimes it was kind of our
understanding or either you
know fortunately it wasn't I wasn't used to we have to get
rid of and for differing so that we all agree is something
organizes the work. So. Listen it really
hard to hear and it's it's really complicated for me because even though it on charm
and there is like a multi-task two things they give you any talk in
there it's kind of like a moose a little mission because I occasionally misunderstood shared
a densely powerlessly I'm actually following
somebody especially too seriously even in school I had to
sit in the front and it always in a fright Actually
it was a professor. But the problem is trying to do my
work at the same time it's kind of heart so I knew this my biggest
disability is right here.
So where did you grow up. I was
born in Queens.
I was raised I was actually
at the age of four or five.
Four five six Berkeley brothers playing reached in Queens
then priest in Berkeley and came back some of those
can only means
.
Seventy six seventy
seventy six to sixty years and what neighborhood in
Queens right now.
I mean I'm still only it
looks like from the sky like between Queens and
socially is for a misprint there where you say never
home you know when I was buying a used
cell phones I saw it was on you know
Rockaway Boulevard you know of the
probes.
Like sprint for us. So what was it like
growing up.
Oh no it wasn't me I was fine family was
feeling of being around people who are missing
and I got some for a plane around.
It was kind of it was kind of
I think it was kind of like vi only because
Bush League currently broke the
English league owned it on growing this
kind of violence and items over his cue to her it was always fights
going on the only being around so many people who
everybody grew up on the scene that was on the black as if you were grown up and you will grow
like a family or not but it was kind of like hard
because for me I was everybody that I was always like why I was
always playing basketball most of those I guess I was like the tomboy because I used to love
sports you know this couple and the football I played
a lot again. So but being around people was kind of hard to
use that people really talk about because I didn't I didn't
have my here and he said I didn't hear him except Tom in.
I wasn't really I didn't pay attention to basically my
hearing but I know I knew I had a hearing problem but I didn't
understand that it was getting worse and hate
to get early testing and hearings because
there's a little disappointing it was too sweet and you know it's going to do when
about to put his cars ahead tubes being put in my ears
but I know it is. I used to watch people to serve as a visual in
reading. People always talk about you and it was kind of late
. I mean really paid attention only good of a C. satellite
whatever work I will walk away because I wasn't the type of person that
it's like to fight or whatever so I have hair like so many negative
comments they like to see for it so are the
people we're in who grew up on. I was
always that why you wanted a little bit just sleep it was like I felt like I was
business more because it was kind of hard. Oh I understand the guy here but did
she say she stays out of their drama and it was kind of saying I'm sitting here
in that era was it like when somebody with a little torn except
especially because it's hard to hear the voice meaning speak they've got a deep voice and when
you talk so it was really you know I just used to keep
whatever but I mean people who make frenemy
happening they just left in this and I see a certain
muted like detention and that sort of ways but with some of the excellent question you
know girls think you know but equally
when I was I used to sit next to a person visit was
that it was called but it was equally nobody like screamed loud enough or tall
very tired so he was talking to me that there's like a death
in the audience and it hit me it's a lot like
odor so as late as I don't you know I notice sometimes I don't
I mean I'm home.
It's it's not late and young girl enough older than I So it's like
we think she's quietly when I go home it's just me and my brother and my parents like everybody
posting only Everybody's in a little room just again.
BURTON So it's legal. Quaid areas and you
know everybody everybody come out and see how far I usually go to the late Margaret
and go visit sometimes you know I would have prickly and mess around with my cousins
sisters and school was even in
college as well as my social years though I don't know a lot of
people who I didn't have any other so there's a lot of
guys also because of my major Being sick of my field it was like technology that's
something that keeps me going through here
he is on so I knew this. And he really didn't have our
friends like I didn't have too much friends but I had a lot of social So it was just
like totally you doing here. Sometimes on his watch or if I have time I'll sit
down but I notice it's
Connelly it's hot it's kind of hard for me to
China roti dignity logically
so I'll leave this meanie for usually sometimes I can get away with a whole lot of
people like you sometimes it do my hearing sometimes I have to just do it because
even my hearing you know I have to balance it when I just hear
the sounds of people who say we have more people that she
was talking to me if I do you know most people in
here and she was handsome.
So here I think it's this way as if I was actually
around your neck you have a gray it's like a long acting
so.
Phone and long acting or kind of and then yeah I was that
it's a it's like a stream a pro it's
someone hearing me and I can only answer my phone.
Oh this isn't my music. Oh oh
oh I can just see if I know I have a teeny point me to just do T.V.
sounds in the host so everybody has a TON of the T.V.
show versus if we made a hex to watch T.V. so
they have their communication in-house and turn everything but here it's a free attorney do
you know that it gives a community to my own tongue
around the house.
So it works to get my hearing so when you don't want to hear the
T.V. you can use the T.V. device and when you want the volume to be
higher in the T.V. you can turn it higher for yourself and no one else nobody
else can hear it will need some of this work this is only because I can hear it on my hearing me well as
my hearing explode so you just kind of like turn the volume up on your hearing aid.
OK so then everything else around you is ample time to you
know this sounds like it's a very well traveled and well as you
could slip if I try to be a sort of phone sometimes.
Well the doctor put a program when he again sort of prissy laughed at their house and
so my phone started ringing. I can press the
button just here but the actual greens if I hear any so into the
ear. Gauges actually hear a person but don't know how to switch of
excellence like reprogram birds that uprights because once the background noise
. When folks go to theater I want to punch a kraut so I can actually
focus on the personalization to against everybody else
.
It's kind of like a live technology. Yes well go to school. Why just strategy. Where
did you see see you know this major computing there were a
technology and a little like fix what troubleshoot
technology trying to learn how to build pro worldwide to
program program and plenty of technology. Now something
they got was always a loved video instantly so much media means all
sorts of like the game being the cursing and why was this
year
. How old I am now twenty five. How do I know you know where I
am games.
I was playing and you know some of
these but since I don't have time I usually play some games and
have played a little games like I have Playstation looked at playing basketball or
Sunday whenever you know it's not. Yeah Year three lovely those games
with time no going to school. And trying to
have their time so easily fix computers and
shooting. Let them do an internal review and rightly
so all this is a school junior high school in Far
Rockaway Beach channel I think somewhere far
away where what do you do. T.
technician that you need to do to actually fix the computers look
at Charlie Sheen the technology and so do you see anything anything he thinks are
basically God to fix it with school. How did you
find out about that you apply for an armed robbers already in school I
mean based on my major from the school of doing all the career
theorists unless. It's like a whole
translation has the hammer phrase and me well it was already part of a programme at the
crash of the kidney gradually since the hair was so well it is programs during the summer
as the two up on the program what are you trying to work around with
the technology and when they went
back to school. I put down my resume in
to after school the school's Korea fear they will still hate people
fitted to areas inside of you and I do you know what was in the novel
too. If you're sending those in Exley to give me a list of schools that I
wanted to participate in. Sister Sharon so I was actually
on essentially a paid internship national finish in June it was funny
because I graduated in the beginning of the
program. Now I'm just an article. So for me to
be in a program about to continue which is what they're supposed to vary
so there we can actually keep stable I feel that there
are a now it's kind of hard at least I'm trying to take it easy because I just graduated
and I'm one of the fish in the game that I had to pull to because now register and
have to make sure that the school is going to hit the series has been made
of the club which I'm going to go to.
So.
So tell me you know
like elementary school you want to
. Think I
went through with it but
they know it's a school in Queens. P.S. ninety six
she moved the hitting it was a year so we
have to point in there was born and
raised here in the bathroom with you know much about elementary school
you know and so do you remember and Metro Middle School
where he went to school.
That's OK
I mean you know going to school in Brooklyn is kind of there's all
this I mean I wasn't there because I was I was a person I mean it wasn't
a school that I was always a person and I
felt like I was a business person and I was always always participated
in it and it was really it was kind of
hard at the same time right.
But about the world like the burn them.
Well what about that was hard
I.
Think I had to learn to get used to changing classes where you got to
switch rooms and room it in it was easy because he was different publishers so
uniforms was different needing a
change of classes and in trying to do work and
it was a drama so I mean school movies.
But.
I mean I've been at it I'm injured.
Although I still have hard to hear and understand it so now I don't know how I was
passing I think I may be able to do for
the feelings of my song because and at a certain
level headed late
or no way banks and there is concern about that they have put
me inside of the special players that adding new players in
either I was concerned but they didn't explain it I felt like it and explain to me
why I was moved and I felt like the students repeating because they kept seeing a specialty
so I lost a lot of us it was a special special especially
special special year of two teachers in the year when
everybody had to change classes and we have to stay there you don't change the courses.
So you know I mean comfortable when I was there but I just never had
to do was to fill out all kinds and
in this state while he's been in this but I think when I started like six Kerry
it isn't really explained to me you were quoting parents you
know I don't know what was split excluding building have a cup of whip
basically where you train for a week I just got a paper.
Everything the people say you know he moved cities to Egypt where they have no
results that it's getting over to try to finish to trying to
gradually years that's what I can
remember besides all the faiths creating the ask what school did you
go to see to ninety six clubs in Bushwick which are in their
right state you have are you didn't participate as you now
really know propaganda closely I mean and they really have much weight.
If a meeting high school is a slate everybody then everybody knows if
we have the thirty people grew up with some appearance people each
other there's kind of like the Who left any area where I lived in the area which had a whole
school those years it was it
was a great I mean really clearly.
When it's when you come home and get out of
school. And those are what kind of things would be all fights about
this some don't quite see that relationships really.
Was she saying he sees. A little he was crazy I don't know he was just so
many aid to schools like planes was at night and I don't even know which story that
they should proceed to aegis of
those that are fights are based on a he say she say so I don't know because I was always in the gym
playing basketball. Well either I think I did a lot of doing to
step into the team.
Dear Daughter please ask me
because I was always around a lot of police play that person's ups
just ask for a plain rope a little bit of
this and I think it's
maybe a hand I think I actually did have one for I guess that on the side of my hip with a
pin I can't remember why
I just heard an about Steptoe
. What if I don't miss out on my head and it was a four year old
I don't know why what was that I can remember it is just a
picture. Let's go to the hospital. Look at the hospital and into the
hospital. He did it worry you were bleeding and there I think was fine
I wanted to be sure of my skin with the guns on the side of my head and
it's up early but noting with the two of us who
was held in a form that I was the first fighter a very
big six interested there was only a freshman
year sixth grade.
Does that mean.
What was a building like that he lived in the building.
Yeah definitely a house or partly it
was a like a partly right
. I like enough already I feel sorry
for the first two floors to be a
different world.
As a first to me my mom and my grandma Flo was
my mom or my aunt my father son moments I want to win the
title for this I wouldn't say before.
So then after my last day at high school where to get a high school high
school.
Freshman year I went to school in ACORN High School for Social Justice
to you in my freshman year one thousand three hundred in their
natural spirit to Queens when you blue moon we moved because
travel for so I went to school in Queens and sold
a lot of forcing the public secretly testing of
Queens
. I'm going to let it out yet again so.
And what it is that when you.
Figure it out.
Technology I wonder do you do you not also always mess
around who those missing became what it was or stuff I was always
breaking things they try to put it back together like my video games.
Please to take my Playstation two and turn it into a turned it
into who own. A computer like the head of windows
because it was able to get in the Internet is somehow one day I
was just playing around I was on You Tube and a motive might be every like
they had already been in a meeting of world a movie
would put it in there. That's about P.S.P. it was in pursuit like you know when I was really
into me it was like oh Mike you saw all of this mean brain I'm
so used to play so much video games and had all the technology and came up
with this like the Game Stick have come you know and
it just came out this computers
and there's always a computer monitor.
Continue your and that they don't really mean that it used to just a bizarre
computer one to really turn off the computer and showed kids the
teacher we should we have to go to the programs and then of the monitor had to show the kids.
Well as a student the monitor had to leak. We should call Peter a show
to make sure the programs are on the computer. So from you
know dear Mr Because I used to have a word specific you would
use in a monitor and as a monitor I
don't think you already did it was late when I was growing up I said
I was I wanted to be a criminal just because I want to get up
and I was really you know want to be a
boss an awesome manager.
With the police or security guards or police officers
something all of the criminal justice inside that field and
the school that came from this beast doing my high school there was a lot different
division society. I mean there were
classes there which is going for a six and it was
programs they hated the school put out they participated in it because
that's what a school with only had two years before we started it while there were three year
and I found a lead about the programs they
like program for Pell P.T.O. we already have like
you train the kids and it's like a program for like programs only
read in the police legally and ethically and I mean
I found out the information slowly so I didn't really think so and it's just going to get
out of school. Double problem now at the school. I tried
doing the best one teen.
No playbook. Splits up people.
But after I started realizing that I didn't want to be
I mean I think we had to get out of his doctor's appointments that way
but I started seeing myself I didn't really have much friends like I was socialize with everybody
. Lunch it is not just like Obama spoke so rarely
and when I knew my hearing Muskegon nowheres was
on I think we had to repeat the ruse. To call
chatters so repeat that we had to see the person being me passing the ball.
He's doing practice and so he puts a cage and I can't listen
to the coach thing I can remember thinking he screen
name and on any Ted
Ted making mistakes is no way they are doing the head of playing
the practice and laying I feel like and the next two days are in
combat. Why because.
Because I felt way
late. I can't listen up and I mean I
hear I mean it was like it was
like it's like nobody caught up with me to see it was born
white and the F. each floor hit here in problems so I didn't feel
as high school my hearing it was like a little bit because like people was a
life ending.
He remembers saying we can only see just what he called my
name and a hand like a really hard time here in Atlanta. So it's like a lot of things that I
miss them with a lot of things I mean things and Indian I notice when I had to take my
tests. An English regions and I feel the English
test because if you're going to take in and nobody did and you know we
had no idea and had an affiliation with a school didn't even know me
and I felt I felt a test by
five points because tweaking so I didn't have any loops Eastern to
answer the questions so I had to take the test a second
time I guess because I was a visual where I was really into personal
attacks.
So as a rent a person lives right things that I would see the
person saying so what were you going through that moment when you're
taking the test and you were reading the person's lips and then you realize that
you like how how difficult was it for you to hear the person.
Actually it was Carmen it was hard when they hardly ever know because my
mom told me you know she was going to sing to the doctor to
see whats going on but we didn't go as soon or late I was great
at that right on this one I think where in between school
graduated this when I went back to the doctor it was it
was it was hard but I don't know I just work and
certain things I think as they got into it so much like anything that I
know will help me do a lot of things is because of technology. I would
get on the computer and Google something if I needed it and he denied it you
know.
Oh yes well you know I mean it's funny for me shit myself
.
It did everything he should have done that I needed to present
They even eclairs I used to get a trouble flicky English because
I was loosely we had to do a group reading along you know the class reading
unit chapter books and reading the story I was currently clueless because
you know it. Give good teacher everybody inside the class read
so we had to go back to whatever. So by the time it was my go because
some people do real well but some people read a little because they were
afraid to read aloud. So it's kind of hard
. So I think you know I didn't honestly you know like I would really unless it's
late I filled it hurt because it was like you know this is going to be paying attention
and seeing the you know in my mind of SR I mean no no but the sea
as I was not my fault that I was you know in the story in letting this day
nobody can't fuck wit me basically based on my hearing even from
school. My hero who's I mean from feeling is Olympics and now
even this one seemingly went a switch and you know I have resources I mean
I had a resource in the tree school with me and taken out of class
for me so it's for ever read it.
And the women fighting over a couple with their different bitching
tools like I do when they do like remotely getting repeating to me
.
Everybody's a little late she said pleasantly Agreed but it was late.
Nobody understand.
I passed my classes because nobody realized that I always look
look at the religious people will lose the going gets leave
like why she stay or leave before you know and I believe
the last I had to visualize the price of two hundred doctors things like Well when I went
to college and because some people are now we're already hearing Beatles learning
but I just grew up reading only it is so strong I
think if I didn't know how to read the area that is
a visual and read it and window here without hearing
it seems like it was kind of like a lot of things.
It's kind of like hard so how old were you when you were you
lad learnt you were reading maps and ingesting on your own no one
you realise that the only way you could understand people was by reading our laps
and and.
And then you found out that your hard of hearing do you hear if there is
a real way. See we knew when I was a baby I was actually hard of hearing. I
wanted to fill out to fill my ear.
Did anyone know that you know my mom you know she remembered
why I don't know that or anything like that but
I'm on your mom up here everybody was like me feeling new.
But growing up being noticed late. But here it was getting
worse. OK so. What I'm saying
in school was like you know what it isn't paying attention to me yet a pizza
agented it either because I tried to figure out why everybody you know
playing I used to just well being maybe an only child I was always an
independent because I was just the only girl you know it's just me about world
. So when the two of us he's only twelve thirteen. So I
mean the only channel like dignity and she being
overprotective So you know it's like kneeling getting ready to hear from you know
how people would you know listen participate you like all I want to do this and get
it but when I realized what I was working in groups like evil we
headed to where I was always styled or information I don't know that I
could have done better. Being
on a plane put myself in a room with everybody
to the end of this communication is kind of hard. Ian Lee Yeah sometimes
I do go see it like I see my counsellor some days later when she
needs to actually go to King she always
told me what's going on. Whatever. So it's like it's kind of
hard even like I notice when I'm around like college people and now when I'm out
but sometimes I feel like when I mean everybody like a group I feel like I'm
left out because it's really hard for me to actually eat. It's a lock and you say things in
our city or even if I felt like the conversation started I wouldn't be able
to now actually trying to find Louis defeat but sometimes it be things that people
talk about that I just don't know I don't want to be involved in. So
yeah like that. So even though now like sometimes they're
its heart like my hearing aids because sometimes I'm just I'm
curious way in school. But I noticed when I first started when I hear unease as
empty I started to feel cheated because I do differently if this is like. HEADLEE
hearing students in that human face. So the first time they started
of they started with a video quirk recorder but it wasn't a
regular video because it was a recording veterans like somebody
come into play music nearly twice the big movie so
they were trying to get a professor and from their point nest started
going sort of Dr Martin over to China Sea where it was actually working for me
. So now that I've found weight and it technology was moving etc My
She has a widow what I was interested when I hear a neat
but I have every now and I've had my phone in
my approach and like at home. So you know people
acting in a lot of jobs they really are a
skater printing different kind of resume your daughter had experience for different things. It's not
our problem is in answering the phones. You will hear her teeth
because over the phone I can't hear it or see a home have a caption call
screen so sometimes I don't hate a person.
These screen thinks that what they say so on the
stand for Sometimes I still don't know what the hearings now to have my hearing me but when I
get a phone because it's quite a I can hear everything but if I don't like and roll out
a new easy area it's kind of like hostility
really balances and I have to like I just ate so sometimes I don't travel in some
of the numbers that are no. Sort of foreign travel to oil simply
because our son he only everything like the streets I hear the car is the
house in the trying to hear the person like it's really hard
to really sleep.
Unfortunately some things I don't think about it this kind is harping
on the old idea it's late as it goes.
They guess it like growing up I didn't really hear you never and paying attention
is like the old adage so late it is because it's
like even my internship since I'll be fixin things like to sing
I'm sitting in the front and the secretary sits behind me
until late.
Three weeks.
She's call them I mean so she goes an equal so so my position equal enormous on but when I hear you
on the level told police that's my notice somebody called attention she
like you little pitch so it's kind of like really
like ours like oh it's when I hear her voice I know which way it's coming from so it
might seem I hear my hearing aid.
That's where the rector person but it's like even though she's talking
sometimes it's like I can't hear Lee I did hear things but there are words
to speak the words I can't really catch what they're saying. At best part
of her ear and basically it's like I've got a speech discrimination and it's like
it's really like Hartley. If they say
well if this is really busy and you hear everybody she's talking at the same time
but I can't write once on the game who have us talking this lake and have a look at
a person that record you see what they say versus you know everybody we said.
That's what I notice when I see it it is our shot explained
you know they find if we use for us to adjust the year we need so much
better because like I knew this night it was a lot of people who see
late in a party let them even quiting office where
within a busy year and you hear everybody like you know like it's like a everybody voice
but I have to look at the person to actually hear what they see
as our film upbringing like my mom doesn't like asteroid
kitsch that reflection is in that rating but I hear your voice but I'd be
like ha good Did you see as the weird things that idiot boy
but I don't know where it's. Because it's kind of hard like I can't
explain it's like it's really already is just like
music like playing music you know legs and Zone music because
it's dear but it was like a lot of people you're still going to have to look at the person
is actually talking to me it's not a listing of of
the only ways but I hear what you said
exactly what it was like it's kind of horrific really being horn here or
something like that.
So what can you do you know your
parents my parents yet which And you were
there they're pretty old programs
like what's your what does your mom do.
It's like occupation.
Oh my mom she supposed the lady she deals with my MIL
and my step dad is he's that your mother
or did they work together to
please your step dad's a driver for
post for like schools like a bus driver
Lego school school school bus school bus driver
and he was one of the leaders.
He's just a boy goes to school but he says
video games for us
and your biological dad.
What's And what's your mom's name for it like that archiving purposes
.
Tosh it's this crisis my step
dad called Mr White
is Joshua
and he's and heavy.
What about your dad has is he let us in love if you
know he's going to help do you know Him Do you ever spoke
to his alone two missing child
. Usually the whole religion then you know the whole of the
leading causes of you so do I have spoke to
sue him. He's in town for you sent
has so he hasn't been in year one thousand.
It's our Anything else you want to say on the recording that we haven't
touched on yet I think you know I'll
say this I think this is a good opportunity to actually expressions the
Yankee is sort of
disability even though I mean like. So that will cause some type to talk
you don't want to always told people like your problems but it is
certain certain reactions that you know you can
light there's ways you can you hope to understand
things to protect yourself.
To not show people why are you doing this because sometimes you know people look at you like
you're crazy, but you do certain things for a reason. So it's like with me
sometimes like when people talk to them sometimes I gotta really look at their faces like
hearing, like I wouldn't want to stare at you just to stare at you. If you're actually saying something to me
and actually looking at you it's because I'm reading lips. So sometimes I have to like, even at work
sometimes I have to be like, yeah, oh no I'm hard of hearing. So you know for me to look
I don't like to say that all the time.
Sometimes it does...I mean
it doesn't like I don't feel like comfortable sometimes, like a lot of times
like
I will still say it though be like oh I'm hard of hearing so like
know and sometimes I have to sit down and be like oh you have to slow
for me I understand
there's a process. I have to like pick up your tone, that's how I feel.
Yeah. Thank you Shanequa, for sharing your story.